good afternoon and welcome
14 of the Columbia School of
International and public affairs and
it's my pleasure to welcome you to this
first lecture in the leaders in global
energy series the centerpiece of a new
initiative launched by sepa to identify
solutions to the challenge of creating
sustainable energy while protecting the
environment and reaffirming corporate
citizenship our speaker today is Noble
Tanaka executive director of the
International Energy Agency but before
introducing him I would like to thank ed
p energy is the port Dougal for the
support which makes this series possible
EDP as you know is one of Europe's
leading electricity operators its
interests in conventional and renewable
power extend across 11 countries on four
continents including the United States
sepa is pleased to be able to partner
with this forward-looking enterprise and
exploring the future of one of the great
issues facing the global community today
the leaders in global energy series
consists of formal lectures and informal
talks by distinguished leaders in energy
from around the world and across the
government corporate and NGO sectors in
addition tonight to the night's talk
sepa will host in the coming months
talks by Fatih Birol chief economist at
the International Energy Agency Andres
pillbox European Commissioner for
development and carlos tavares vice
chairman of renault-nissan please check
the CEPA web page for more details on
these upcoming events I also wish to
thank sepa visiting professor Manuel
Pena who you see sitting just to my left
professor Pino is the former portuguese
minister of economy and innovation he
served as the director of the european
investment bank and as an economist at
the International Monetary Fund prior to
assuming his ministerial position on
August ninth 2010 the New York Times ran
a front-page story examining Portugal's
global leadership in
transitioning to renewable energy and
noted that Pinot quote largely
masterminded the transition in fact I
think Elizabeth Rosenthal the author of
this brilliant piece in The New York
Times is here today treszura Pinot has
also been the driving force behind this
lecture series in Portuguese you would
call him the intellectual author part
mill turn off my cell phone it is he it
is Professor pinos deep knowledge as
well as his energy and enthusiasm that
have made today's talk and indeed our
leaders in global energy series possible
he will moderate the question-and-answer
session that will follow mr. Tanaka's
remarks and now to our speaker nobuo
tanaka began his career in 1973 at the
Ministry of Economy Trade and Industry
in Tokyo this is the ministry that's
affectionately known as meti he has
extensive national government and
international experience with enmity at
the Embassy of Japan and Washington DC
and in the OECD he first joined the OECD
in 1989 as deputy director of the
Directorate for science technology and
industry and was promoted to director in
1992 in 1995 who returned to meti and
served in a number of high-ranking
positions the most recent recent being
director general for the multilateral
trade system department in the trade
policy girl in this role he led many
trade negotiations under the aegis of
the World Trade Organization in the
energy field mr. Tanaka has accumulated
vast experience he was responsible for
japan's involvement with the IEA and the
g7 energy ministers meeting during the
second oil crisis in 1979 which all of
you of course will remember was even
more serious than the first oil crisis
of 1973 when industrial nations were
faced with a three to four hundred
percent increase in the price of crude
oil in a relatively short period of time
in the late 1980s he participated in
establishing japan's comprehensive
energy policy and he oversaw the
implementation
of Japan's international nuclear energy
policy and led negotiations on bilateral
nuclear agreements he helped to
coordinate Japan's domestic environment
policy and energy policy in the third
Kyoto conference of parties negotiations
which as you know led eventually to the
kyoto protocol's he was Minister for
industry trade and energy at the Embassy
of Japan in Washington from nineteen
ninety eight to two thousand mr. Tanaka
took over as executive director of the
international energy agency of the OECD
in September of 2007 in this position he
has emerged as one of the world's most
serious farsighted and clear-headed
analysts of global energy issues it is a
great pleasure to welcome mr. Tanaka
pasiba Andrew Columbia
thank you very much for very kind
introduction and I really thank mister
peeny Oh for inviting me to talk to you
oh yes we work together in our say
energy field when I started energy sake
area in the IEA Minister Pina is the
most respected an innovative and dynamic
minister I ever see so you are lucky to
have him here and to innovate you yes as
dean explained to you my career back at
Japanese government I spent a lot of
days outside of the country so in that
sense half of my career in up in the
ministry's outside of Japan and very
unusual for the Japanese carrier
official on the other hand that gave me
a great opportunity to see the world in
global issues and that gave me the
opportunity finery to head this
international energy agency when i
joined meti it is 1973 the fast energy
crisis happened and when I moved to in
the middie to the energy sector who is
dealing with the energy issues
international energy issues it was
nineteen seventy-nine and the second
energy crisis happened so when I got
that job in IA many people told me that
hey mr. Tanaka if you move to again to
the energy international energy sector
you may invite the third oil shock and
it happened in 2008 you remember that
energy price oil prices went up to one
hundred forty seven dollars per barrel
and it was really serious oil shock for
many countries
but this gives you a good thing thought
about now we have to Syria think about
the energy security issues much more
than before because this may lead us to
the very difficult age of how we can
reconcile this energy security together
with climate change issues
sustainability issue but we are saying
this is not conflicting issues we say
this is the same mutually supportive
issue in our discussion so I try to
convince you by using our recent
publication call this energy technology
perspective 2010 to you and discuss
about climate change and also energy
security issues let's move our slide and
we are created as i said in 1974 in the
past oil shock in arab oil embargo of
the oils we are created by henry
kissinger when he was the secretary of
state as a counterbalance power balance
to opec oil producing countries we are
the consumer countries union and holding
90 days of net import of strategic
stockpile of oil and use it in case of
emergency we used this tool twice in the
history in 1991 when the fast say crisis
or desert war gulf war happens when iraq
invaded quaid we mobilized this to
second time it was 2005 when hurricane
katrina and rita hit gulf of mexico we
mobilized again two million barrels
day of the lilies collectively so our
concern is energy security but now this
energy security means a lot to the
sustainability because best way of
securing your supplies not using the
energy so energy conservation efficiency
in the demand side measures very much
important for us of course to move away
from oil we have to use coal we have to
use gas we have to use renewables we
have to use nuclear power so
diversifying sources of energy helps a
lots of energy security but except call
it helps the co2 emission reduction so
our projection for our analysis is the
real input to the climate change
negotiators these years it was not the
case 23 years ago nobody wants to talk
about energy or example nuclear power or
carbon capture and storage because these
these technologies are considered not
sustainable but now without these
technologies simply co2 emission
reduction is impossible so dialogue
between environment policy makers and
energy policymakers are very much rival
E and cooperative and talking together
in the same language that kind of
dialogue is happening and this is a big
change in these years let's move to the
next slide and showing there are plenty
of security issues not only oil as i
said the blackout of electricity is
suddenly the very much of the energy
security issues which had hub happened
in the united states couple times
already the gas security is a serious
issue in europe when the gas supply was
disturbed
through you through Ukraine then the
sustainability or stability of the
suppliers question from Russia how can
we do that can we have the strategic
stockpile of gas but it's very costly
than the oil so suddenly I a its role is
expanding not only oil to gas gas the
electricity and we are moving toward
more comprehensive energy security and
to make this comprehensive security
possible we have to talk to not only I a
member countries we are only OECD
developed economies the major economy
emerging economy is now consuming a
quite a rapid dread expanding the
consumption of energy so without
engaging these major players outside I a
we cannot really secure the source of
supply in the future so these are the
challenges for me how can we make our
international organization I a relevant
in the future not only now but in the
future this is the challenge other
executive director of this organization
that we move to add to what is this
energy technology perspective means two
years ago we publicize this book and we
called on the energy revolution is
necessary is this energy revolution
happening but what we need to do what
kind of technology we need where we have
to invest and how much these we try to
answer these questions and are we seeing
some of the changes which we want to see
more that we call it green shoot our
green shoot happening this is another
question which right which we try to
answer let's move quickly this book this
is what would happen from now to 2050 if
baseline energy
we'll look like we have certain serious
down i would say trend in 2009 because
of the economic crisis but after the
thousand nine 2010-11 the recovery is
now happening if business as usual no
government is not taking serious policy
the primary energy demand will grow by
eighty-four percent from now to 2050
that is a baseline the four slides a
four bar chart to the left and you can
easily see where that growth happens
because economic growth is almost double
in non-oecd countries compared to the
oecd so most of the energy demand grows
happens in these areas and mainly from
coal this is another interesting feature
because coal is achieving abundant china
india is using a lots of coal for the
energy source but it is very co2
intensive so can this really changed to
the more cleaner or less intensive way
abuse that is the technological
challenge policy challenge oecd
countries energy demand will not grow
it's already for example in the oil it's
already peaked in 2005 and it's now
declining so how can we i mean if we
have the policies we have to engage not
only our members but other members also
that is our challenge next judge we try
to develop the alternatives we call it
blue map scenario maybe some of you are
quite familiar with our document called
wild energetic which is annual flagship
publication we call it 450 ppm
stabilization scenario basically it
means to reduce co2 emission by half
from now to 2050 which is a scenario
which IPCC or unfccc
the climate negotiators are aiming that
what would be the scenario the what what
kind of technology is necessary to
achieve that that is what we try to
answer the field emission will almost
double that by this 450 scenario we have
have it but energy of course use will
increase but the issue is how to
decouple energy demand growth which is
which should happen to make economic
growth possible but the couple co2
emission and growth economic growth the
next slide is the answer first the top
line is the business as usual co2
emission the bottom line is that so
called blue map scenario which is aiming
at having the co2 the best technologies
maybe many of you know that is energy
efficiency it is most cost effective if
even though even you can gain by
investing in energy efficiency so thirty
eight percent of the necessary reduction
should happen in energy efficiency then
we have to decarbonize zero carbon power
sector decarbonizing the power sector
either by ccs carbon capture and storage
nineteen percent renewable energy
seventeen percent in nuclear power 6
process but that's not still enough we
have to decarbonize the transportation
sector using the d carbonized
electricity electric vehicle or plug-in
hybrid or fuel cell hydrogen vehicles
these new advanced vehicle is necessary
and that is the most costly part of the
deployment
next chart is where these reductions
should happen two thirds of the
reduction should happen in non-oecd
countries China 23% in PR twelve percent
of course this does not mean who pay who
should pay for this reduction sadly the
developed economy should put the money
what transfer the money for this happen
but this shows the opportunity because
the economy grows happens in these
developing economies it's inevitable
that reduction must happen there how can
we make it happen by technology transfer
or financial transfer that is the
difficult political issue next slide
shows what would happen if this for 50
or blue map scenario happens in this
primary changes in the primary energy
demand that the left hand side is the
current level the red is business as
usual and blue is a blue map scenario
fossil fuel should definitely decline of
course but coal is typical one if
nothing happens call expand dramatically
more than double but it should reduce
thirty-six percent oil consumption must
be reduced by about twenty seven percent
from now and gas this is interesting
natural gas is very important sources to
reduce your permission because it's
relatively clean so north america in the
united states thanks to the so-called
non conventional gas gas shales lots of
new potential for cheap gas is available
so the trial power sector is moving away
from coal to gas but yes this is very
important as a bridging sources but to
our 2000
50 globally the use of gas should
decline otherwise co2 emission reduction
it's very difficult gas is not the final
solution unfortunately we have to move
to nuclear hydro renewables biomass all
these zero carbon sources is necessary
by the way even with this very dramatic
change the fuel I've been fossil fuel
dependence is still forty-six percent in
2050 this is surprising current rates
eighty-one percent but still we have to
depend on fifty percent on the fossil
fuel in 2050 even revolution happens so
this clearly means that we need to
invest into the for sale still
continuously in in the coal in the oil
in the gas in conventional conventional
oil sources non conventional gas sources
oil sand gas shale wherever possible we
have to keep on investing otherwise our
future is very very challenging why next
chart this is a price assumption of the
oil when the business as usual happens
no government policies taken the oil
price will move up to 120 dollars per
barrel as a real price 2008 price
nominal price is much much higher of
course if for 50 or broom up scenario
should happen it should go down it's go
up to about ninety dollars but going
down to at seventy dollars per barrel of
oil because demand is low i said
twenty-seven percent less demand so
suddenly price producer price will
decline but it's only producer price
because in 2050 our model tells us that
carbon price which is necessary to make
this efficiency gain
so renewable energies or nuclear happen
the carbon price is $175 part on of the
co2 this is the additional price on oil
in a sense it converted to about seventy
three dollars per barrel of oil so yes
producer prices seventy dollars but
consumer price is 140 some dollars so
whichever the scenario the oil price is
getting higher otherwise this co2
emission having is simply impossible so
the difference in two scenario is who
takes the rent is it all producing
countries or a consuming country so from
our viewpoint it's obvious which is our
choice for the consuming country we
should take that rent and invest this
rent to the renewable energy energy
efficiency carbon capture and storage or
nuclear power and you can create the
jobs there so this is a choice and we
think the choice must be obvious but
this is most difficult politically to
convince the politician to accept higher
prices of energy higher prices of AB
Kasserine gasoline tax issue is most
politically sensitive issue here we know
that but we are now start saying that
cheap energy age is simply over we have
we grow very quickly on the combustion
engine internal combustion engine and
chill oil this is the 20th century in
the 21st century we must live on the
different paradigm high energy prices
and how can you adjust yourself to the
system in the business or country or
this is a mega competition whichever the
country food or company
who establish the new business model a
new paradigm will win this is a very
interesting mega competition which is
happening now next slide this is the
power sector portfolio the two scenarios
on the left is baseline when government
is not taking serious action major part
of the power comes from fossil fuel coal
gas etc we prepare three different
scenarios on the right hand side blue
map is half of the power sector be
supplied by renewable energy solar wind
biomass hydro and a quarter by nuclear
another quota by mainly carbon capturing
and storage of course if carbon capture
and storage is not readily available we
could have more nuclear 38% new Korea
and in that case nucleus little cheaper
than that venerable was Theseus so the
cost is ten percent less compared to the
blue map hi hi nuclear scenario is
electricity cost is ten percent less we
could have higher renewable 75% comes
from renewables in this case we have ten
percent more cost so yes renewable is
very good sources but you have to make
more investment in smart grid or storage
of electricity or demand side management
so it's more costly of course you can
choose costly but again here the cheap
energy or electricity ages over you have
to pay more for cleaner electricity next
chart is more striking to achieve this
for 50 or broom up scenario how many
more
energy infrastructure is necessary to to
be built we have to build like 50 CCS
plants abria it's not yet come as a
proven technology we have to build 30
nuclear power plants every year from now
to 2050 we are building only one or two
area now can we do 30 historically yes
we did some time before Chernobyl we
built more than 30 nuclear reactors
historically so it's not impossible but
it's challenging we have to build about
16,000 windmills abria we have to build
solar CC CSP concentrating solar power
plants 55 since ESP power so we these
are all and and and and and it's not for
alternative we have to build all of
these things every year to achieve this
plume up scenario so yeah so we are
always asked our mr. Tanaka is so
optimistic about that you are telling
the future but we are saying no no we
are not forecasting what would happen in
the future we are back casting if we
have to reduce the automation by half in
2050 just back cast what we should do
now so if you see this at the back
casting maybe it seems much more
pessimistic then this is a reality check
from our organization to the climate
change negotiators are we ready to
engage ourselves this level of
investment can we really deliver this
otherwise simply talking about the
target of co2 emission reduction we can
go nowhere it is scientific friction
we have developed several roadmaps
technology roadmaps this is wind yes
currently its European say Europe has a
plenty of wind mills and also us is
coming but major increase should happen
in China for example and other
developing economies and as a whole the
wind can play provide about twelve
percent of the electricity to our 2015
we are sometimes criticized this this
prospect is too low the windmill makers
say we can do much more yes that's fine
if it can be done more we we can have
less nuclear we can have less CCS so we
wish to be wrong but yes wind has huge
of course potential next job this is the
photovoltaic roadmap we have developed
recently yes currently it's still photo
baltic is very expensive but 12 2020
maybe residential use of photovoltaic
could be grid parity these are the
retail electricity price in a utility
the more mega use of photovoltaic maybe
takes a little more time of application
and larger deployment and probably
polity will happen around 2030 but
certainly at this moment we need good
incentives like feed-in tariffs to make
this kind of technology happen but
gradually of the technology development
they are coming to the parity because as
you see that to rinds moving up this is
the general cost of retail or wholesale
electricity it's getting higher and
higher anyway so the parity will happen
in the future next chart is
the very interesting data which we had
the recently accumulated by electric
vehicle a hybrid this is we calculated a
number which the many countries has
announced or companies has announced
China US Japan Korea France in 2020
already seven million new vehicles like
this will be on the market but in fact
in our blue map scenario we have to see
about 1 billion vehicles on the road as
a stock in 2050 so we need much much
more electric vehicles on the street
next chart is the trends where how the
conventional gasoline engine is going to
be replaced by other technologies as a
new car there are quite a limited number
of the sales we expected or should be
expected otherwise it's very difficult
to reduce your commission again we
praised by praveen hybrid electric
vehicle or fuel cell vehicle we don't
know which technology will win
eventually so we just put about a third
each for possible future but suddenly
feel so is more costly for hydrogen
deployment or platforms for the hydrogen
so electric vehicle were plugging hi
praveen hybrid could be the good option
next slide this is the smart grid what
kind of benefit we can get from smart
grid direct co2 savings or an indirect
savings it's one for one or two Gigaton
of the savings is probably possible from
smart grid smart grid is is necessary
to use more renewables of this volatile
nature of the renewables we need new
technologies and designs next slide
please this is that calculating the
benefits of this investment we need the
left-hand side we need forty six
trillion u.s. dollars of investment from
now to 2050 additional investment but a
benefit is the downside 112 trillion
dollars could be saved as a non used
fuel and mainly it is it happens in a
transportation sector the investment is
also the case more than half of the
investment is purchasing new type of
beko so if not not in the nuclear power
plant two are windmills but it's the how
to invest into the new type of vehicle
is the major investment and the benefits
also comes to that segment but important
thing is yes then if it comes gradually
every year after the investment so how
to finance this future flow of the
benefits into one initial investment
this is the challenge next factories
this is the co-benefits chart as you see
the many greens compared to the
right-hand side most it is a benefit of
co2 emission reduction by the different
technology compared to the coal with
just about critical technologies in many
of the new technologies is friendly to
the environment friendly to the water
usage etc so but we have to watch
carefree of these core benefits in
analyzing that different technologies
that sup it says next chart please
and let's see the regional configuration
regional differences I talked about all
global numbers but we can analyze for
different regions one is US Europe and
China and India because all these
countries has a different pattern or
different policies United States yes
other business usual line I mean the co2
emission will not increase very much but
us must reduce dramatically from the
current level to 2050 even us must
reduce by eighty-one percent from now to
2050 while Europe should with you
seventy-four percent China will increase
to add 2020 but reduced gradually by
thirty percent compared to the current
level on the other hand India can still
grow by ten percent in 2050 because
depending on the different stage of the
economic growth the different level of
pardon sharing of co2 emission reduction
in our calculation but per capita basis
this is interesting per capita emission
of the United States is very high but it
should go down very quickly to 150 12
almost similar level in different
countries so the challenge here is how
can we really incentivize the lifestyle
change and reduce this much of the per
capita mission china yes certainly it
may have a very high per capita but with
new technologies china may come into a
new paradigm it has a huge opportunity
with the new emerging economies of
experimenting and introducing new
technologies new lifestyle and lead the
world and we know that for example China
is a most serious country
investing into the electric beko it has
a very ambitious target of energy
efficiency and achieving it so yes China
is that going to the currently the
largest co2 emitter at the one country
and almost largest energy user now
almost close to the United States so
without Chinese effort nothing can be
done that is true but at the same time
it provides China a huge opportunity of
leading the cleaning up or new green
paradigm let's move quickly to the
comparison of the fuel demand just in
all countries yes the pasta affair
consumption must be reduced especially
in US Europe but for China yes oil
consumption from current level it should
increase I mean this this show how
significant the Chinese fuel use look
like compared to the other region yes
oil increase or gas must increase much
more currently there is a gas glut
because of the new non conventional gas
from the United States and LNG
facilities is readily available so there
are gas glut and gas prices is very long
now but if China starts importing LNG's
this glut will disappear quickly so gas
is certainly very important bridge
technology but it depends how the China
start using us next this is the
comparison of the power generation in
the right hand side is the blue map
scenario and depending on country this
portfolio is is different US must use me
much more nuclear power and wind bio is
also important Europe is using lots of
the renewable energy
china india also it's very important to
use CCS carbon and capturing otherwise
it's very difficult india's is promising
in a more solar power so each region
depending on this endowment of the
different resources the different
portfolio is a massage next slide please
this is the industry sectors in the
united states in dust europe about
two-thirds reduction in the industrial
co2 emission us the same thing while
china about twenty percent reduction
india india in indian case india's
should continue to grow so the theater
mission may double even in this blue map
scenario that efficiency fuel switch
low-carbon capturing and storage is the
answer in the industrial sector to
reduce the automation next slide please
this is housing major part in the
housing sector building sector the
rectory I mean decarbonizing power
sector may help but otherwise yes more
efficient appliances or building
installations depending on a different
country different option we show in a
building sector but building sector is
certainly very important for co2
emission reductions next is Biko the
United States is currently that already
China exceeds the vehicle sales and
India will surpass the US around 2030
and you can see which kind of vehicles
it should happen combustion engine Baku
will disappear as a new car but it could
be replaced by the hydrate hydrate
electric vehicles fuel cell yes huge
business opportunities but at a chain
that challenge for the government to
facilitate these changes because
infrastructure of electricity or or
hydrogen this is the very interesting
policy issues can one country has a
different system this is another
interesting case next this is the
message about technology policies carbon
pricing is important but should be it's
it cannot solve everything by itself we
need other complemented technology
policies and we have to design carefully
that these policies up to the level of
maturity of the technology public alandi
still must be double the government
should you know use the stunt field I
mean standard for the field and
efficiency there are lots of the
government roles in making this happen
next slide you can see clearly that we
say that depending on the technology we
have to design carefree the technology
policy when it is a premature technology
yes government are indeed grant or
subsidy is necessary but when it comes
up to the ladder yes less
interventionist approach is necessary
maybe feed-in tariffs at the beginning
but between premiums or tradable green
certificates in the end you know just
carbon pricing may may work but we have
to have the different mechanisms for the
different technology development stages
that what this slide shows next this is
final one at the beginning I said do we
see the changes yes we have we are
seeing the changes the green shoots we
say
in 2009 the photo ball take about six
gigawatts of photovoltaic who's
installed we see as I said seven million
hybrids or electric vehicles are coming
by 2020 what large-scale CCS project are
moving 80 of them we have identified
incandescent lighting buffs phase-out is
happening or government funding is
increasing but this is not enough to
make this blue map scenario happen we
need for example 46 gigawatt of the
photovoltaic by 2050 we need over 1
billion plugging in electric vehicle by
2050 we need 3,000 CCS project by 2050
the LED must dominate the lighting
market the government funding must be
double or five times more than the
current level so much much more we have
to do to make this energy revolution or
historic transition to make reality and
I was invited to just recently to the
clean energy ministerial meeting took
place in Washington and my final message
is yes we are observing the historic
transition already but that's not enough
the government in private sector can do
a lot and engaging these non-member
countries is also very important in
Cancun we will have a very important
cop16 meeting but we should not we
should not wait for the global deal
climate deal because we know what to do
and we have to do it otherwise if we
delay these measures the cost of
inaction or delay or by one year is
additional 500 billion u.s. dollars to
go back to the trajectory so act now do
that thinks what you think is necessary
each country can contribute action and
that is the message and I'm very happy
here today with many of the faculty many
of the students here and especially I'm
very happy that mr. Pina told me that
many young people are now interested in
energy sector energy sector used to be
the dark in black and dirty and nobody
is interested but now we have part of
the solution and not part of the program
thank you very much
thank you very much mr. Tanaka before
passing that asking for some question
would like to thank the words of the in
cos word I mean this initiative it's
your merit exactly one year ago we spoke
for the first time and you had the
vision and the leadership to make this
possible and I thank you very much we
could not have someone better than mr.
Tanaka to you know great this lecture
mr. Tanaka has been one of the world
leaders in energy he is doing a
fantastic job at the International
Energy Agency and at least my students
will have many opportunities to see what
the agency is producing in terms of
leadership we have two alternatives
either we don't do anything and we know
what will happen in terms of energy
security and co2 emissions or we take a
task which is extremely difficult but
probably there's no alternative to that
and now I would like to take your
questions please
it's my pleasure to ask mr. Lanker this
question in your latest slides you
mentioned carbon pricing policy should
be implemented with other policies so I
my question my first question is what
are those other policies the second
question is without money transferred
from the carbon credits market what are
the other are the sources of this
massive investment to renewable energy
are we expecting to another stimulus
package despite two questions thank you
yes other policies means that the carbon
price is a very important part of the
necessary incentives but as I said when
the technology is primitive you know it
cannot really make the changes so the
government can use R&D support measures
into the new technologies or you know
not the carbon prices but some
incentives or for example for the
efficiency part the government can set
the standard of shields economy
standards interesting it's a very
important one so you can the government
can force the private sector to to take
these standards in and there is an
implicit price of carbon happens by
doing so so the government can do a lot
depending on the sector depending on a
technology you can develop many other
things and on top of that carbon price
especially this carbon price is useful
to covering the power sector maybe
industry part of the very carbon
intensive industry but for the
renewables yes it is very important
but at the beginning we needs some more
yes the stimulus packages was a very
important step to put some money into
the renewable so we appreciate the green
New Deal policies in many countries we
calculated these impacts and but
stimulus package is only one time so we
have to say that we have to continue
these investment in renewables by the
government are the seed money and also
invite try to make certain framework to
make private money moving into this
segment and continuous effort is really
necessary otherwise just investment will
not happen then you create a typical
case if government changed policy of in
favor of nuclei and not favorable on and
off on and off policy then no investment
happens so predictability for the
certain period time transparent
mechanisms gradually phasing out these
these these measures this is not
sustainable if it continue forever so
government should set these incentives
in a very transparent and predictable
manner otherwise investment will not
happen my name is alia sherry I'm from
ciba Energy Association thank you for
delivering this wonderful speech I have
two questions the first is where they
got to China which is the biggest I
guess the most important subject when it
comes to energy future mr. Tanaka we we
might remember that you promised that
you want to engage you want to engage
China more into IEA and I want to know
at this point what's your what's your
commitment toward that promise and how
is that going to be without the the work
frame of OECD
my second question is a bit technical
but he really feel a field curious about
is the limitation we might have on
carbon carbon sequestration we know that
carbon sequestration is is meant to
inject back co2 into the ground and we
know that most of the co2 will be
produced in the consuming countries
while the co2 can be only injected or
will be limited to mean sequestration
would be will be limited to with your
physical constraints yeah my question is
how is the technical feasibility of co2
transportation and how you evaluate this
in your neural organization thank you
very much thank you for the second
question first yes ccs is certainly the
issue is that already there's a
technology of capturing and co2 but how
to store it this is another story yes
storage certainly we need to need some
legal framework if the leakage happens
so we need blow-up demonstration plants
that the Greek edges can be avoidable
yes just geological structure is
necessary but it's not only consuming
country because many of the producing
oil producing gas producing countries
use enhanced oil recovery I mean using
co2 pushing into the oil fields or gas
field to increase pressure and getting
gas or oil out so ready already these
technologies used in some of the
producers so so so transportation even I
understand that in some countries
interested in transporting co2 back from
the consumer country and sell it to the
producer country to using enhanced oil
recovery if that there is high enough
carbon prices it could be an interesting
business model to the liquid natural gas
is now transport from produce
to their users on the way back this
empty lng vessel could be used to move
the co2 from consumer to the producer so
that is the new technology new business
models China yes we have been engaging
China in many activities in the IEA
already they come they came to the many
of the meetings a ministerial meeting we
have the joint statement and work
closely with the statistics we have
already 12 every month or two we have
the statistician came to IA and Chinese
status in learning about the energy
statistics this is very basics but
fundamentally important to have a
comparable statistics and they finally
decide to send the policy staff to work
with us as the second D so it is moving
toward the future engagement sadly to be
a member to the I a current say
statutory agreement requires the
membership the OECD Chinese not
interested in member in OECD so to make
China as a full member certainly we have
some legal and diplomatic challenges
that from in our side also but as I said
with to maintain the IEA the relevant
energy security player we need to have
much closer tie with China or India or
these emerging economies and this is
moving step by step
my name is Bogdan voici and I'm
assistant professor in the school of
international public affairs at Columbia
I just have a technical question you
showed us a graph that showed the growth
of the wind energy industry and which I
believe was twelve percent reach about
twelve percent by 2050 and as you know a
major obstacle for renewables and wind
particular is the power infrastructure
in particular the development of
high-voltage direct current power lines
and infrastructure so I was wondering if
you have any examples of where you see
positive signs and and if you see if
you're hopeful that this energy
infrastructure will change at the pace
that is needed we have analyzed the cost
of Buddhist renewable energy electricity
as a whole and suddenly onshore wind is
promising in many countries already in
Europe the wind is providing quite
substantial part of the electricity and
other mechanism like feeding feed-in
tariffs and 12% number is relatively
modest in renewable high scenario this
number is about twenty-five percent so
it could be as high as 25 yes and also
very interesting development in Europe
is that there is a project called a
zyrtec why it is sometimes called
military Pam Mediterranean Grid project
portugal is a very active player france
spain germany the idea is building
concentrating solar power plant it's
solar thermal plants in the North Africa
because they are so rich in a direct
light so connecting these solar to the
Europe
through the high-voltage direct-current
grid as or even there are some idea of
super conductivity grid lines because
superconductivity graded zero loss so
with this new technology in the grid the
North Africa is will be connected to
Africa to to to Europe and Europe needs
about I remember five terawatt hour of
importation to make this let's say blue
map scenario possible so yes it's a huge
challenge for investing in these
infrastructure but Europe is very
serious about it's getting more and more
serious about these investments so we
would take now the last question naka
thank you you said today that because of
unconventional gas plays that the market
is well supplied and you proved said the
same thing about oil how soon because it
seems to me that if you're going to get
any real action among politicians which
is going to take a supply constraint so
how soon how far do you have to go out
before these supplies get eaten up the
excess supply that is actually a price
to start going up again because of the
supply side oh you mean the peak oil not
necessarily peak oil but how soon are we
no longer talking about excess gas and
oil how soon is it a constraint again
but if we consider the conventional gas
or a non conventional oil it is we think
it don't have to worry about peak oil a
peak gas because if we have enough money
and if we don't worry too much about
price level there are plenty of
resources underground the problem is
above ground some countries limit access
of
international oil gas companies to the
resources the technology cannot be
deployed we may not have enough
investment and price volatility hinders
investment so we think we have enough
non-conventional sources but this source
is a costly because it's what could be
deep sea it could be more difficult
place in like Arctic it is more new
technologies for shale gas shale oil
while oil sands so these
non-conventional sources are are more
expensive so inevitably regardless of
peak oil or peak gas you know we may
have the sources but more costly more
expensive our scenario this blue map
scenario is not the peak oil scenario
because now it is demand peak scenario
so how can we make demand peak happened
earlier than the supply peak that is
this broom up scenario means and we can
postpone or extend the future
possibility of peak oil happening into
their long-term future so that is what
this scenario means so that again means
the very climate change oriented but
energy security more energy secured a
scenario so as I said yes to convince
the people investing to these actions we
know we need to have these actions but
climate change argument is to do
something for somebody else energy
security is to do same things for your
own sake for yourselves so this is much
more politically acceptable argument in
the United States in Europe in China for
so there comes the reason why I a
organization can play a role in these
discussions we our role is energy
security and we provide data analysis
arguments into the public domain so that
is the current would say mission and I'm
very happy to be with all of you today I
want to conclude by inviting you all to
a reception in honor of our visitor mr.
Tanaka and professor p nu which will
take place right at outside this room
but before doing so I guess I already
done it I want to thank our
distinguished visitor for his wonderful
talk and for his responsive answers to
very tough questions thank you